[Music]
he traded cocaine for paint
though talented he ain't white house
officials
have helped form an ethics agreement
with an art gallery to sell hunter
biden's paintings
so that he nor anyone in the
administration won't know who bought
them
or if they were sold by the ounce new
york
new york gallery jorgez bruzzes which is
french for jose's brzez
is pricing the pieces between 75 grand
and half a million
and of course those hefty prices have
nothing to do with him being the
president's brat
i'd say read between the lines but
hunters snorted them
i don't laugh but it's as much a
coincidence
that that his art career began with his
father's presidency
as his hacked laptop story was killed
right before the election
but under the agreement the gallery
owner must keep bidders and buyers
confidential
and reject any suspicious offers but if
the paperwork's in chinese no questions
asked
the whole thing is just the latest
effort by the administration to address
absurdly legitimate questions
about how hunter makes money like why
his paintings have to be smuggled across
the border inside
someone's butt but when you have a
presidential family member slinging a
product with a highly subjective value
that's a problem as walter schaub former
head of the
office of government ethics noted
because we don't know who is paying for
this art and we don't know for sure that
hunter biden knows
we have no way of monitoring whether
people are buying access to the white
house
so are they buying art that's crummy to
launder hunters money
and did hunter draw that flower to
exploit his dad's power
you've got to wonder what his dad thinks
of all of this
look look i'm just glad hunter has found
a hobby that can make him
some money for a change i mean let's
face it his last few hobbies
fairly expensive and this whole thing is
on the up and up
i mean it's beautiful man it's like the
price is right
only nobody knows who's bidding there's
no way to overbid and instead of say a
refrigerator
you're bidding on something that looks
like it belongs on a refrigerator
so don't tell me this isn't a great
country man
thank you joe kagan
it sounds to me like the white house is
now running the art gallery
right because the art gallery has to run
all of their decisions through the white
house
so they've just opened up kind of like a
a a satellite art gallery for hunter
yes actually that's where i go to buy my
panda bear paintings
yes that adorned my bedroom do you have
big giant eyes
yes they do i love paintings where the
animals have big giant eyes
almost like teardrop and they have a
textural quality
yeah so you can touch them they're like
fuzzy
i know this is a little bit it really
keeps my victims company
you can sleep on them cats you can lay
them on the ground
and sleep on them i'm into that well now
you've gone too far
hunter biden can do whatever he wants at
a reasonable wage
but he's trying to make money like you
buriesma board member
and now these paintings of someone who
actually knows what the hell he's doing
yeah so he wants to she can sell
paintings
on etsy for forty dollars that's what
they're worth but not
five hundred thousand dollars this is
literally the equivalent of him coming
out and saying
i'm gonna be a 51 year old white
rap star and i'm charging two hundred
thousand dollars to
like perform at this hedge fund
manager's arbor day party
it's the same sleeves jessie's doing
that by the way
[Laughter]
well he's been practicing a lot in the
bathroom you know uh
joe what do you think of the art in
general
uh i've seen wallpaper that i thought
was better than that
but hunter biden's the only person i
don't blame it just seems like whenever
he gets a job he starts
at the top yes which is pretty cool i
mean
spending half a million dollars on a
hundred biden
high school caliber flower painting is
effing ludicrous no offense
offense to people that had sex with my
favorite rapper
i'm glad you cleaned up that joke yeah
yeah
and by the way it is it's not grade
school it's it is grade school painting
because the it's below i didn't realize
this but this is what kids did you have
children right
brian as far as i know yes you blow you
blow
he blows the paint as opposed to
snorting it he blows it
this is something that kids did during
like before nap time in in kindergarten
right i mean it's that finger painting
or blow it it's one thing the other
whatever makes you happier uh a couple
of things it's amazing
the hunter bite was in the news twice
this week uh first was for his paintings
which he started doing last week and now
he's getting up to 500 000
for it where everyone agrees they should
not tell anybody who it is that's
actually buying it
uh number two the other story was oh by
the way
there's a picture of him with two of the
richest people in the world and his
father
flew them down together to meet in
mexico where they would eventually set
up an international deal
involving barisma and ukraine but let's
focus on the paintings that go for 500
thousand dollars by some mystery buyer
this is the craziest story and hunter is
so in your face
you know what he's saying no matter what
i do i can't get touched nothing could
ever happen to me
and no one's ever going to ask joe a
tough question so we have to sit here
this is
as far as the hunter biden rumors go
your circle your
your circle of trust this is as far as
it goes it's crazy yeah you should see
the circle afterwards
ain't no trust in that one don't know
what i'm saying
[Music]
cat um would you uh
how much would someone need to pay you
to put this in your tiny little
apartment
uh i mean if i was getting paid for it
that'd be one thing but i don't have
those advantages right like
you know when you play video games like
mario kart you get like power-ups like
you like star power like the thunderbolt
if life were a video game the greatest
power up would be power
dad yeah because it doesn't last for 10
seconds it lasts forever
and if you like fall off it doesn't
matter you can fall into crack addiction
and you
just fall into a lucrative art career if
you have the power dad
you can do anything you want but i don't
have that so i would
i don't have enough money to buy one of
these pieces of crap you know that you
know who's really pissed right now is
avenatti watching this it's like
he broke way like let's face it hunter
broke gun laws drug laws
uh laws involving strippers power dad
our dad
that'd be a great video game yeah you
sleep with a hooker you get a thousand
points
yeah yeah how many points would you have
it'd be a cheat
[Laughter]
a jab from the fox and friends anchor
over there excuse me
excuse me i have a first name okay how
dare you you're not gonna vicariously
through joe over yeah you don't mind do
you
well you made a little mistake you know
that hunter's been painting for over
a year now right oh you're right yeah
yeah yeah i have to correct that because
it's embarrassing when people from the
morning shows come on and
drag us down to their level
i just i just pointed out you asked the
morning show guy you keep
asking me asking me why i'm here
i don't think this is the worst
relationship ever
and i keep on playing but you keep
coming back
but what is my problem i don't know at a
certain point you got to ask yourself
i did i'd rather ask you but then i
always i always hug him and cuddle him
afterwards
and he thinks it's all okay until the
next show
all right up next the words hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else